pellicule affiches ou photographier tous
ces objets conservés aux archives
françaises du film sont issus d'une même
famille au cncc produits forment des
collections jean baptiste travaille au
service de valorisation des collections
sa mission les rassembler et les listes
et pour les rendre disponibles aux
professionnels on peut avoir pour un
prime par exemple le négatif déposée par
un laboratoire une copie déposée par la
famille du réalisateur ou le réalisateur
lui-même
et puis quelques éléments de travail et
puis on peut aussi avoir d'autres copies
dans d'autres versions déposée par par
un collectionneur donc
beaucoup d'entités comme ça différentes
qui en fait constitue donc un ensemble
de deux films de collection qui se
recoupent les unes les unes des autres
fonctionnant comme une bibliothèque il
est impossible de tout conserver le
service fonctionne donc sur les choix
exhaustif dans le choix aussi notre
collègue de l'enrichissement que l'on
peut faire et n'ont donc qu'une démarche
là vraiment volontaire de notre part on
essaie de prendre des choses très
significatif de est représentatif donc
de la production française des archives
qui proviennent de dons de laboratoires
ou des ayants droit mais le cnc achète
aussi des collections des collections
qui ne sont pas seulement sur pellicule
niché dans une des salles du site de
bois d'arcy se trouve l'idée derrière
acquisition du cnc voici l'écran
d'épinglés un appareil inventé par
alexandre alexeyev éclaire parker dans
les années 30
acheté en 2012 par le cnc c'est l'un des
deux seuls exemplaires au monde qui
fonctionne encore le principe est
toujours le même depuis 2 2 puis sur
l'invention deux années trente à savoir
un écran une surface percé de trous en
quinconce dans lequel dans chaque trou
il y a une épingle
qui coulisse et donc ce n'est pas comme
dans les fameux jouets que l'on peut
avoir dans le commerce le volume
que l'on produit sur chaque épingles qui
va former l'image
là c'est l'ombre portée de chaque et
pain qui va former en fait au final une
image comme l'ancêtre du pixel cet outil
permet la création de films d'animation
un travail minutieux et chronophage car
ici on travaille image par image
chacune d'entre elle se forme en grâce à
l'éclairage rasant à 60° la surface
pourvu de 270000 épingle l'utilisation
d'outils particuliers est nécessaire
pour travailler sur cette surface
le plus important c'est de manipuler
dans ses épingles à avec des outils
principalement envers pour faire
attention avec quel type de verre cette
ampoule elle est assez épaisse donc ça
va elle ne risque pas de se casser ça
peut être aussi des outils en plastique
pour peu que le plastique n'est ce pas
de dépôts sur le début de la surface des
épingles sinon l'écran on se salit et
donc ça peut être aussi des objets aussi
incongru que sept petits jouets là pour
animaux ou qui en fait si on repousse un
peu sur la surface
on va créer donc une texture comme
toutes les collections l'appareil est
disponible professionnels l'année
dernière le cnc amis l'écran d'épinglés
à disposition de plusieurs réalisateurs
pour un travail sur le cinéma
d'animation
un outil qui est donc à redécouvrir pour
un résultat au cachet unique